it's Monday and I want to welcome you
back from my city well don't ever send
me a text and say no don't ever send me
until this is my city
you and crystally anytime I said that's
that's that's not that New York City and
also we don't know where your cities
that I could make your story so hard to
follow dude I'm from New York I don't
know yes I grew up in the unlocks at
India I have an aunt very soon that I
moved to New York really actually when I
was 20 here's the thing here's the other
thing
roots are in New York right hook is on
the subway
he's ignite all time growing up we got
so long where I was and finally Bryant
around wit I don't know where I'm going
by the way I never learned the subway
never sub-points trick can't read the
map the subways tricky I can't [ __ ]
read the map I go excuse me where do I
go J Shabbos put us in this trendy hotel
and Soho 11 Howard who wants to be there
whatever those these rappers staying
there let me tell you something out of
problem with 11 Howard well they have a
club upstairs to stay near the table
yeah well that music doesn't shut down
around 3 No so poeple got no sleep I'm a
light sleeper he's light sleeper and you
need to shut it down as your big man and
correct me if I'm wrong you you took on
the daunting task of doing three shows
now that was that was that both nights I
know cuz I've riding Friday - yeah I'm
in Calgary I did it and I've done I've
done at six and twos a tough one yeah I
did it Gotham I did three shows at
Gotham where I did it and by the way
when you're done with two shows people
don't realize new to the meet and greets
you're tired
most mounts I've ever had as well sir
500 I believe now let's savor that
really yes now after that you got
another group waiting and you go oh it's
12 a.m. and there's a line out the door
for me no Papa didn't hit stage two 1:15
a.m. well there you go simply too late
did the meet-and-greet at - that's too
much you know what though you can only
do that in New York if you do in LA like
midnight show get the [ __ ] in my face
York you can do it though shirk hit pact
no one was belligerent and I was no one
was loud they comes back to collate it's
a Europe I came out said you get you're
some hardcore [ __ ] you guys
came to this one pit one am show you
gather down inaudible I said Amish cut
too short by about 30 minutes you have
30 minute preview it's like
just now daddy daddy decided to do three
shows I believe this was the order I
said I'll do three shows Gotham and then
daddy decided to do the next weekend and
he went up to Denver where it's a mile
high he had a little cold he had a cold
and the elevation and the elevation said
that he did three shows then although I
we keep calling ourselves daddies but I
love because we've been around they're
going daddy now then daddy went to
Toronto didn't take a break oh by the
way flew to Albuquerque finished
shooting the show in plain sight working
on that show then decided to skip on
over to Toronto and that's when he ended
up in the hospital that'll do is I
couldn't breathe he'll run your dry I
couldn't breathe go run you're drunk I
was like even when I lie down I'm having
trouble breathing and I went to the
hospital and they did heart tests on me
oh wow you have exhaustion that'd do it
they made me stay there all night
hey how about how about I was doing
press on Thursday for Showtime from
literally eight non-stop I had 30
minutes to grab coffee in a quick lunch
Jay Shaab was with me yeah I did press
from 8 a.m. to 5 p.m. and we get done
Jay goes what do you want to do I go
dude I got no sleep last night doing
press all day I'm freaking Terios just
press though wait
why yep dude hi there's a pure rage in
me when he said that he's flying about
now he's listen at work I was like what
did you say he's all it's not like
you're working it's just press leak I'm
gonna go get coffee over here drove me
nuts you guys get so mad at each other
one time you had an argument about you
and Willis and I almost blows we talked
about were like casino who and he was
saying something about well being a mom
isn't really that much of a job and you
were like hey you [ __ ] idiot we're
this close
how does like Brennan you're so in Jays
face right now you're like it is a
full-time job and I was like even me cuz
I get heated too yeah I was like hey
dude you take it easy over here and
you're a rough flight that's the
brotherly love that's their brotherly
love right good oh yeah
it's rarefied then we get over it well
Jay won't back down
there's your bigger brother so he'll
he'll come back with all different
points but he also doesn't seem to stay
mad and he doesn't he doesn't be tired
doesn't say mad and there was nine
thought not did on Saturday we watched
Central Park
all day and I argued with them how boys
get sucked off that night there and he
beg to differ I should talk to Brian why
Jay goes Jay goes that was back in the
day now it's clean at night no I said to
the rambles what that's what I told him
it's dick-suck central walking around
knows that I mean I'll walk through
there and suck his dick right now make a
point that's so in the end I mean it
that way but I'm just saying maybe here
you meet him argue that in the entire
Central Park walk I'm like dude I'm
telling you to dig sector he's like not
anymore they cleaned it up no no no he
really only cleaned it up oh he didn't
no don't clean up when grown men at 1:00
in the morning wanna bang it's they
throw him around Jay said Jay goes I'm
gonna walk here at night just to prove
to you guys the way you prove me a get
you just walk through the rambles I know
yeah I told you this story I walked
through it at one morning in Central
Park and I got that there was just dudes
like that I've never been a Central Park
it's really nice oh yeah what are you
talking about a gas car that's where the
Ryan lives and performs we got to go to
Central Park
it was cool there yeah my mother wants
me to fly in now there's a family
reunion now when you're on TV I don't
want to say this it's not I'm not saying
anything about my I'm not sure my
family's but there tends to be this idea
that because you're on TV it would be
nice for you to be a family reunion
maybe because it's something to talk
about maybe I don't know maybe you're
the center my mother my mother's proud
of well you basically the pig with the
Apple and his mom well my mother's proud
of me so maybe my mother wants to her
cousins and stuff to see that her son
made what did I don't know that's not my
mother's style but I'm just saying I get
now can I come can I be your manager
until your mom yeah cuz cuz let me let
me just say what my mom wants to Malik
Allen she says I'll fly at Planet redeye
at 10:30 at night after you shot all day
and correct your idea with the shin so
flight flight and then you go all the
way to New York yeah in the morning
premiere at about 6:00 in the morning
you take the red-eye yeah I take the
red-eye and then and then hang out on
Saturday and then come back Sunday morn
now he can that can I tell what I don't
think mom Macallan 75 grand that's what
it would cost for me to do that but he's
my son I know I'm sorry
I could be a CA a thing I'm sorry you
try to shoo bribe me she goes I'll pay
your ticket Wow
laughs yeah 50 grand I feel like I
should do it for my mother
yeah it's your mom but but you know how
that makes me feel I got it I got it you
know how much I hate to fly and I do
what happen and I didn't say what happen
to nubby I know it's funny yet when the
horrible things happened I left my head
not be no snowed outside little black
guys she went to get the mail slipped
broke her shoulder shoulders not fun now
I say it broke her shoulder you know the
bulb that holds the shoulder and socket
yeah that thing decided to snap off oh
so now bees on her top fur yeah
bruising Maya my dear friend Frank
Martin passed away for anybody who note
with the brain tumor tumor he died on
Saturday at 8:43 a.m. I'm in 43 am yes
home he was saying he was in the process
he would they put him in the Bronx and
one of my dear friends said that's where
the hospice was that's where you go so
so so initially when he was in pain and
in California T when you're in a little
bit you know what you can't tell if
somebody's actually in pain but when
they're sort of in and out of
consciousness and their having kept
having seizures so you sleep in a lot
yeah yeah and so so but if you're his
boy if you're my boy and you're going
through that you know what I want to do
and I know it's the end hold their nose
and mouth uh yeah hey you hey Doc give
him all the more fall yeah let him have
a good run real give him all the
morphine and put him out yeah and one of
my buddies was like my buddy's like I
don't want my boy in pain I've known him
for 30 years do me a favor doc and the
docs like there's a limit to what we can
do because that would be euthanasia I
can't do that all right dr. Kevorkian
right so you can't do that there's a
limit so they kind of you there's a
limit to how much they can give you so
then they move into they moved into the
Bronx and he's there and comfort of his
own home yeah but my friend who if
you're from New York fine goes no not
the Bronx whatever the Bronx like that's
not where I wanted to say how honored I
am a liar but not depressed but I mean
he he's back in Virginia where he's
being laid to rest next to his father
but he was a great guy so Frank your
friend yeah it's above died like a man
man he never really complained he
laughed all the way to the end and all
my friends like John Paul Busey Robbie
Weingard made him
how old was he he was fifty three young
kids anything nope no kids no wife and I
believe both his parents are deceased
oh yeah six seven the tall man dude I
tell you sometime big dudes don't last
long name the biggest grandpa you know
I'll wait
chin they the big guys gonna cry next
bro the big man go fast
yeah but why don't live the good life
and he was a great guy it's good it's no
mystery gonna go it's cool to go on like
your own terms surrounded by his friends
go pax went he was at his house staring
out at the Golden Gate Bridge and they
said he just looked at my aunt was like
took a big deep breath and boom wow
really
yep yeah it's a weird thing like how the
how the engine if depending on the
disease you have but this particular
cancer it was almost like the engine was
sputtering yeah like you know and then
and then it just goes down and then you
fall asleep yeah and then you just go
away you just fade away you don't again
well thank God we have morphine and also
when he went to the hospice they got
special [ __ ] you know they they make it
comfortable at the end of your life for
sure in a very dignified way but I like
that you know it's cool because I
realized how how good those people are
in New York like Frank was surrounded by
friends oh yeah all the way around he's
[ __ ] stepped up yeah all great
men yeah dude I just found out my house
the house that I bought there was a
house old house that deftly flatlined
and obviously built my crib above it but
the house there I was talking my
neighbors they said that they the shirt
owners probably by the get in place they
said before that my house was built the
person who lived there was an old lady
who had polio
she used to have brackets on her on her
legs and would just stand in the window
and staring at the Rockies and then the
people who like a coast lady well know
at the time then she'd passed away and
the daughter from my neighbor's would
take care of her then she passed away
house got leveled [ __ ] Scrooge McDuck
comes in right someone else buys the
house i buy it from them but they used
to ask the neighbors cuz they'd go out
of town south I messed my neighbor's did
you see anyone in the window they'd be
like yeah we thought you guys were home
oh my god
oh no ghost lady I know but that I was
like was she friendly she was like yeah
McElveen spray just chillin man yeah I
don't get scared yeah now did I go to
the bathroom this morning past my closet
thought I saw something scurried back to
my [ __ ] bed yeah I did okay and my
girls say like lights turn on randomly
and [ __ ] my grandmother I come from the
most cynical family that doesn't believe
in any of that stuff like where where my
even heaven like my grandmother was
gonna die she knew and she goes and said
well you know in the afterlife something
something my grandmother went if there
is an afterlife
that's super gangster but a ghost sir
like that's always so scary it's but
what's more afraid of scary though Oh an
old lady with polio ghost or a little
child a little child dude but I get like
there's too much love in my house
there's no evil spirits um but there's
some old lady some old bat still staring
out the window whatever she's not gonna
hurt anybody
yeah I tell myself anyway so I I hate
this place called sounds racist so baby
steps called uncle boons tie in on New
York like a world-famous Thai place
there's some [ __ ] Buster got us in there
and J and Buster award my food and I
thought they were [ __ ] with me cuz
hours before the show it was the
spiciest food of all time the spice I
felt my stomach felt like it was in
knots the entire show now for ten for
ten I do I paint the toilet brown is
that what you're gonna ask yes yes yeah
you your your [ __ ] by the time it was
Thomas Coyne was like a dragon's mouth
it was exhausted when I eat spicy food
now I can I can go but then when it's
time for me to to let it go it's I'm not
I'm not holding I thought it was a joke
how hot they ordered it yeah it was so
[ __ ] hot you know why they put spices
and food you know what I came from
probably preserves it right yeah the
other stupid [ __ ] questions we had no
refrigeration yeah I told you Frank when
he was doin our fight world and they
talked about this on the other thing
where it were in Cambodia after they
fight no ice no ice
your face is just so swollen I know um
speaking out if I let you in the eye
speaking of fires that get dumped ice
weird you hold on first of all first on
with the fights where did you watch the
fight that I was there you went to a
rare
Frank Rampage Jackson such a sweet guy
great guys such a great guy what a
[ __ ] he's such a he's a guy's guy
he's a guy's guy but he's also really
nice very friendly yeah and and funny
who he would be all over a cat well oh
my god those black guys I'll hook her up
and he's not a bad-looking man at all
he's like I told you I was at a club in
him in Vegas huh
partying there's all this is on his
young man I just got down the Ultimate
Fighter partying with rampage I have my
shirt off he puts his chain on me on top
of the table dancing there's just all
these hoes around then I like Phenom
talk to someone I look around and it's
just all Asian girls I'm like why the
[ __ ] did everyone else go he only likes
the agents really yep yeah he's a he's a
good guy man really really really good
dude and so that was cool to watch it
with him joe carnahan with my boy Frank
Grillo some other people don't because
part of hand did the movie with him
right the UH 18:18 yes so it was really
cool man I talked to rampage do you have
fun out here man with rampage I don't
think we ever trained together yeah um
yeah I was talking I was talking about
what I was like how did you suck down at
205 sir it's like dude well he's thick
it's a nightmare
he's that big not that tall you know my
height a little taller me man not even
aa thick thick very thick yeah I saw the
fight I was I was there to fight I gotta
say unless I'm ringside not going to
fights let me explain why you got a oh
you have a bonds and you have a box
meaning I watched on meaning I'm still
very far away and I watched it on screen
you still get the [ __ ] letter so yeah
now it was Tony the Geoffrey I said next
time oh no I forgot to mention him sat
next to Tony by the way Tony for being a
great boxer and you know I couldn't get
any like I'm like how was he doing that
had before well no he doesn't he doesn't
really follow boxing anyway he doesn't
and also he didn't really have I was
waiting for him to and analyze it like
give me that but also doesn't want to do
that is that what it is yes but he's
like yeah he's good yeah like hey can I
get I'll sit next to you dude I need
some insiders inside cuz I'm obsessed
with
[ __ ] uh what you think the fight overall
well I'm gonna give you my first of all
I love the fight personally to that now
um and I'm gonna give you my my entire
assessment lease I believe that so so
there's no doubt that Tyson Fury is a
much better boxer than the other Walter
and it was it was yeah it was just a
really really interesting kind of
exhibition on on what the difference is
between a real boxer who's been boxing
forever and somebody comes a little
inure to the game doesn't have as many
tricks doesn't he's got kind of like I
think that that I think that Tyson Fury
knew and could see very quickly that
there were a couple things to worry
about when it came to Dante but down
didn't have the tools and didn't know
and I caught a little at the end yeah
well I couldn't believe how good Tyson
furious head movement was and everything
else now so so I but but the thing about
Jayantilal is you have to remember a
couple things number one he is almost 50
pounds lighter I think which is how is
213 now now and here's the other thing
the man is he's not a very good boxer in
in comparison to Tyson Fury however I
believe I love the decision of a draw
for the rematch but I believe that at
the end of the day if you knock a dude
down though that way especially in the
12th round you should get the fight now
I couldn't believe how many times he
missed Tyson Fury I thought were gonna
argue about this that we're on the same
yeah because I see I
I'm not even opposed like I don't think
I can see I say if he knocks him down is
the biggest moment of the fight I could
give it to Wilder I like the draw I have
the truck know why being because in
those first especially the first six
rounds after seven Wilder starts to take
over but in the in the sixth one through
six those rounds are so close to judge
you're telling me
Wilder didn't win two of those six first
rounds or out of twelve rounds he didn't
when two of those besides the ninth in
the 12 yeah yeah of course then I have
it a draw
a hundred percent I have no problem and
let put online like when you take away
hey did you see a what do you think I'm
like didn't watch it but online I was
like Fox fury must have dominated one
through twelve this was even close fury
if you if you're there and I'm gonna
watch it again fury laid much a lot more
leather on his face but again
the style right so so what would what
but again I don't believe Dante Wilder
took any damage what is yeah and then
there's a in the seventh round fury
lands a one-two flush and you see a
little bit of craziness out of Wilder
brother and that that knockout in the
twelfth round horn Lee I don't know what
was more amazing that knockout or the
fact that our boy got up that he got up
and kind of won the rest of the round
right I was like what's going on Judy
was out I mean his eyes were open I
thought well he's done and I thought
there it is and this [ __ ] Dan
towada has such he always has a chance
here's a gift he's a hard punch in the
world yeah
so who you are and if you make one
mistake it's over if you make one this
Texas thing yeah that knighting tyson
had that same thing you make one mistake
against a guy who can hit that heart and
he did make that mistake my mistake but
really in the 12th round and here's my
whole my whole pitch on below the belt
was a lot of us were skewed because we
all wanted fury it's a great story so we
were blindside by that so even the round
was close fury he I found myself doing
that because it's such a remarkable
story yes if you take away both their
backgrounds both their stories and you
watch the fight from but just a non
biased opinion yeah it's I have it as a
drama man yeah I do too I know it's not
the popular opinion people are me upset
now give it a drop because because like
I said like it like you said just give
Deonte two or three of those rounds
which you have to dare him three when I
fight I'm just saying to and at the
middle and and by the way but I again if
you had given it to Dante Wilder I
wouldn't have been mad only because he
did the most damage and you I mean that
the first knockdown okay hit him on the
top of the head the second one in this
day and it's a testament to down to
Wilders ability to stay composed cuz he
got him frustrated he was missing a lot
he was fighting he was trying to box a
very good boxer with a lot more
experience it's very easy for a lot of
like guys like that to get frustrated in
for Russian he stayed composed he's got
a lot of self-belief oh yeah
and he's I thought was a great fight but
I think me and overshadow because
everyone's like this what's wrong with
box and they got robbed like no one got
robbed I have it as a draw and it's
actually like great story for it's great
for both of them they're gonna make a
shitload more money everybody wants to
see the remainder in the driver's seat
now the hansteen Joshua
no longer your cash cow everyone see
this they decide when they fight jealous
that's what's great about this now now I
think Joshua
I think Joshua because he's 250 pounds
I think Joshua beats Deontay Wilder
because I think josh was an excellent
boxer especially when you get up close
Joshua gets hit but if he gets in he's
got to get in cannot stay outside them
Wow see that's a great this is why I
love boxing that's a phenomenal
heavyweight is because well it's but
it's completely different
Joshua versus Wilders [ __ ] apples to
avocados different than wild or he
doesn't have the head movement that down
oh he tells get hit I'll sit the
Entertainer it's a great fight because
that one is not going to decision now
fury verse Joshua I like fear I always
said Furies my dark host horse to beat
anyone if he comes in shape with the
right frame of mind he meets both of
them basically now he has more tools he
a better boxer he win by decision my
worry though is that that that knocked
flash knockout because he's got he's got
head problems I worried that where he
goes from me I worry about that I don't
know it seems like he's on the rice like
he was fine he seemed like he was
[ __ ] fine it's all here you this is
what we need for in order to make the
rematch even bigger we need those
pay-per-view numbers to be pretty solid
which I'm hoping they come in between
350 400 right anything over 300 is a
they're going sizzler is it possible
that when he got not sound like that was
he just resting no he was out now and
then came to him got back up did when
went so that's straight right Lance
you're like oh my god
on the way down the left hook from
[ __ ] to school from Alabama
oh and that's when and could his could
his could his lower legs be any skinnier
wilder yeah
duties 213 pounds and and if there's a
cruiser and and that's because his legs
are sticks and it doesn't make a lick of
difference because he can still knock
you the [ __ ] out and hits harder than
everybody he hits a lot harder than that
giant man
yeah he's hardened anyone he's ever
[ __ ] look at Luis Ortiz Ortiz it's
amazing well that's the other thing as
the Ortiz is a great boxer phenomenal
and he's older and mentally fit he was
also
kind of a baktun wilder and Wilder
eventually after da grounds knocked wild
it now he knocked what one he'd knock
him down but he wobbled the father yeah
yeah
but while don't starched him yes he did
here we go oh [ __ ] that was so bad Wow
Wow a lot of water dancing and a lot of
people think like that just crazy how
crazy the a crowd won when they rematch
this the crowd went so crazy when they
showed this I'm replaying they stood him
up yeah look at him look at him look at
look at him back he's ready and the kind
of does well after this day he does very
well mrs. Wilder comes crashing in and
he catch him watch watch right here he's
covering up coming up gypsy king
incredible he can wrap you up there you
go just that's a real skill man everyone
you should give employed me oh that [ __ ]
like oh you just grabbed guys it's a
real skill because I love boxing so much
and you know I try to work at it and
stuff and I said I watch old fights I I
have so much respect for defense and and
guys who can not get hit and hurt that's
to me what I love watching I think I
think both guys won this that night I
think I agree on it's a great great
fight the rematch gonna be bigger no
one's a loser
no one got robbed boxing isn't crooked
that he rocked oh my god still caught me
not love fury yeah Andy on things I love
money not love boy loves girls I love
them both that's the thing I by the end
of the fight I was rooting for both them
I you know they're just both beautiful
human beings yeah they're rare men
they're [ __ ] rare human beings
there's whatever it is whatever it is
that they're made of that that allows
them to do that on the 12th round that's
a very that's where you see what a man
is made of that's his character how
about how about what his character when
I turned it on I was in the green room
they rent it for me been the Gotham
comedy club did yeah and I was in the
back when I turn this growl it well
those are the two biggest boxes I've
ever seen in a ring they sure they look
like comic book yeah sure
just [ __ ] huge it's incredible but
his ability to not not to not only slip
the the left hand but then the right
hand as well over and over he's the most
skilled have
on the planet it's in crop Joshua can't
do that no outer can't do that these
teas can't do that the bird can't do
that
why can't do that and what's also
fascinating to me is that if you holding
feels not an eye it's not the athlete a
lot of these guys are but he is who is
uh uh wow I mean not fury I feel I'd say
fury is yeah he's that's what I mean
it's it's it's hard to look at
somebody's body or how him you're like
he's a great athlete phenomenal ass
right look at him okay
I forget that ring is not containing his
because that's probably concur I hate
how it's always overshadowed though that
oh it's someone got robbed that [ __ ]
what's wrong with box you know it's a
beautiful decision I agree one of the
few decisions in boxing it made me feel
good
me too then I agree with ya yeah and and
the heavyweight division by the way is
more exciting than any vision now man
correct well I can't wait for I can't
wait for if ro Spence and Crawford time
yeah yeah February because I thought
Spence is fighting um who else was he
five I thought he was fighting not
Porter he's not fighting Porter Porter
is a current champion hmm because I
can't wait for that Herman is a warm-up
and then yeah I'm sorry it's all spent
Union my cure my bet so it's Earl
Spencer Mike Mike here yeah that's gonna
be exciting but that's gonna be great
but I feel like it's just too strong I
know everyone thinks you I think Mike
Yoshi gets it done mister fundamentals
really the the frickin Tim Duncan a
boxer yeah Tim Duncan of boxes I can
give you a great interview now he's not
gonna give me any huge promos but but
that's no medals that's relevant
fundamental Atta system they can just
you know sometimes
yep although our oral Spence jr. I
talked to our boy who fought him who are
our friend Earl Spencer oh uh
Chris Chris spinard and I said what may
I can't see what he's doing it looks so
fundamentally look like he's just
throwing jabs and writes these explosive
is his ability to stay just out of reach
like just out of reach and then come in
he can he's got really good to he'd
measures distance better he's amazing I
think I think Earl spent there's
argument for Mikey Garcia especially
Erwin Loma chenko but he's lighter has
come to
she's not as stiff as the other guys but
I think the best for it pound for pound
box on Planet its Terence Crawford yeah
yeah no notice no one's really talking
[ __ ] don't ever done okay anyways he can
figure you out with a mighty Garcia Earl
Spence great fight there's some guys
that seem to be able to figure it figure
you out in in real time right so once
they come what is my Floyd was so yeah
I'm always fascinated with guys like
then I find it fascinating though
everyone is talking [ __ ] to fury and
Tyson and Deonte it's because they're
because they're they I believe that they
are they're threatened by their
character and their example I think
you're a weak person if you knew that I
really do I know I think you can't admit
that some people are great and that was
greatness and that rapier greatness
that's what I felt about Canelo when he
fought triple G again I was like you
just proved your greatness and that's
how rare that should be revered you're
also winner dude huh you guys witnessed
Saturday night between Wilder and
furious it's history man every division
it was such an X to both forty you know
and it's forty no think about that by
the way and in people say well Dante
never fought anybody not every one of
them out he fought yeah we're teas is
tough
stubborn was no punk Ortiz was a Ortiz
is an Olympian and a great fighter and
[ __ ] fury beat Klitschko I mean
you're talking about no they got
themselves there I got themselves there
I loved it I loved it Wow I got I came
straight from the plane and couldn't go
to my house so did you fly straight from
this morning no yesterday ok came
straight from the airport to took my son
to see wrecker
now going off three hours of sleep from
doing three shows got some good sleep
the entire I could not tell you one
scene from wrecker off to I woke up to
my son going Papa Papa as the credits
were rolling at the end
yeah cuz I was like did you like he's
like yeah I'm like fantastic I was I
went to wicked with my two children and
my wife or Pantages oh nice by the way
you should really take I've been I think
he's too young boy Shyama bored on it so
he's too young yeah yeah well I and I
that's I've never seen it's a famous
great great musical
I I you didn't like weekend no I loved
it I loved it I really did love it I did
fall asleep for I needed I needed my
half hour not too long bro I there too
long in my wife that my wife went she
went gang and forked me really just like
dude come on I was like oh sorry I'm out
of them that I love it she goes yeah for
this apart you were awake I go I was
awakened that I stay awake
I have troubles to go it's a four hour
that's like Hamilton now first like oh
this is cool the rap you know it oh wow
10 hour now and they're still rapping
yeah okay it's a lot of it's a little
mission see ya
musicals are a lot of musicals you
should be an hour it's hard because the
book is a long time but did you know if
you know them and sweet gets [ __ ]
good though dude it's great it's great
now which can seen your ass off
oh yeah well that did the original was
Edina miss out means out Oh [ __ ] from
frozen yes sir
that was she with the originator let it
go let it go go well I mean this date by
the way when you go to a wicked or
Hamilton and the Pantages that cast is
not slacking they are as bad as it gets
they're doing one with beetlejuice and
then they're also doing a King Kong one
oh I'm missing both of those I miss Bo
I'll go to beetlejuice I love me some
beetlejuice yeah bring up Indy Nimmons
out I want to see what she I mean I know
she looks like where is she from what is
her uh she's married to takes I think
she's very sexy she's married to take
digs yeah she was for many know she has
a jaw like quagmire but I find her very
attractive as well I'm in there I'm in
there boy I said yeah now could she take
a better punch me of course
yeah but she's just talented as on oh
dude she now google hurts our youtube
her singing frozen chin now did you know
this he thanks for there do you think
her and Kristen Bell make the one in the
red I don't just want to take a look
what's going on and make sure
everything's under that dress yeah yes
yeah breast Brian very cool um it's a
very attractive woman yeah she's
attractive for sure um yeah YouTube her
chin but did you know people thought her
and Kristen Bell made like crazy amounts
of Monica's frozen was like the biggest
hit of all time well Disney knows this
like here's your contract
we can have anyone do this yeah now
they're gonna make more off two and
three but like the Toy Story guys at
first you're not making Scrooge McDuck
money yep it's the two three and four
correct which ones you like oh let it go
hit that top one let it [ __ ] go to
let it go man oh can we see John
Travolta introduce her and get it her
name wrong I think this is where it does
that has you seen how he introduced her
I'm no I'm no one to comp you forget
names wrong I get my sword Isis hey if
sewing goes hey you bring up this guy at
the Comedy Store to pray it's where my
first or her name isn't enum is it means
Allah says there will always be a
special place in my heart for the movie
musical and for the songs that create
their most memorable moments here to
perform the oscar-nominated gorgeous the
empowering song let it go from the
oscar-winning animated movie frozen
please welcome the wickedly talented one
and only telly [ __ ] up and there's no
turning back
I've done the same thing I'm just gonna
go all-in he want y'all to believe like
you thought his name he went and the
beautifully wickedly Tennant explained
see and didn't know let's say there's an
art collector myself know how count
these gods of all feel amazing do not
see gaudy if you're a fan of you worst
movie I've ever seen in my life
you are famously we're infamously
however you wanted you had this you
mispronounced her name what happened no
okay the truth yeah not that you're not
telling everything so you go okay we'll
see you then they said oh by the way
we've changed the Adina's name to a
phonetic spelling I what what do you
mean go so I go out there and I get to
her thing and I thought hmm
what is that me know that name and it
was this phonetic spelling but I wasn't
I didn't rehearse it that way so this
was goldie Hawn's fall
yeah so that's a terrible general now
let's see her she's awesome man and and
never get plastic surgery as a man I
think that's the other thing I've
learned it's just too much just have I'm
never doing that alright yes you damn
well well I think she's very sushi and
think it's just the combo of her and
Kristen Bell together have you watched
that you haven't lived then bro how's
the sick of this song issue you think I
don't know what she's singing well not
stop hey the audience often that's what
I think you know what
no it's Myers it's Maya it's better
that's why it must be check check check
idiot girl where the Mickey Mouse's you
know what she's having off night um who
crazy face when she hits those notes
though so when I saw audition mmm stuff
are different things go to her assistant
Bell for me you got a New York City and
you go in and sometimes you go to Bernie
Taupin casting directors school you know
his casting directors office and you
would hear some of the best Broadway
people come in blind or without them and
they'd be how to stand in door and you'd
be waiting to do your [ __ ] dumb
commercial for cheeto lay or whatever
and there's real talent that real crunch
I mean real crusher my [ __ ] these things
got real crunch I mean real like [ __ ] oh
hey I'm like I suck I completely suck
god damn and you think you just hear
these incredible go down they don't seem
that song no no yes go to the very
bottom one was she's in red that's one
yeah that one it's about consignment did
you know she can sing I did just lives
in Venice out of this level yes she and
sing opera
that's her background
[Music]
I'm not familiar with this one this is
part two I know this is the first one
she ain't gotta hold her own against oh
yes she can and that's a big deal
I was [ __ ] up in Tina Menzel's name
alright well there you go thank you
thank you well Janice what do you think
of their pipes I think they're good yeah
better pipes out there but those are
good yeah well no no but I'm not a hater
I'm an observer as long as that is
that's a good point sailor observer cuz
as good as they are when I listen to who
sings that song rise up and read a and
your day when I hear Andra day sing or
something like that I'm like I mean
that's a whole wait here have you heard
him live though not on your album live
the difference there's the [ __ ]
tonight bro it's yeah live is rush she
can [ __ ] it rides up live yeah do do
a cruise no that's that's the video bro
no it's acoustic love nah do that is
that one but real quick when they do
these yeah it's also a process
afterwards hold on to get let me hear
that you're right
yes I Heart Radio she can sing she
[Music]
doesn't need any but a guitar
yeah the guitar could take a hike kind
of [ __ ] me things up in me with a real
singer let me get the guitars
distracting her an Adele she started it
was about say I got her and I tells my
number ones no I mean they started like
a road trip together just and call it
the one to call it the one to first to
open up Bryan Callen and Brennan Shawn
before we give her this beautiful let's
get right in brings they're gonna crack
some couple laughs hey guys guys guys
don't dip backs for it with all females
they deal with dicks huh all right all
right know if it's like that's good
though that's real good chin chin or
whenever you asked about music is the
same thing when you ask any other comic
about someone special this is my
impression of chin and any other comic
yes about some special and asked me
about a special what do you think of
that special all right
I don't say all right they did no any
cow I've ever met dude you see that
special all right
although some of the specials I saw were
I really like like I really liked most
of especially the first 45 minutes or
maybe half hour of Sarah Silverman's I
thought she was great I would see is in
Newland uh yeah I just love she's great
funny as [ __ ] and just good and outside
the best special I've seen so far lately
was big Jay old cousins he's great he's
another one you talking about a guy's
been doing it for 15 years he of course
he's really good funny would Sarah's yes
like of just Trevor Noah made me [ __ ]
laugh two men
yeah I mean you know I think the LEAs
30-minute special comes out soon on that
January it's awesome hey Jeff there
recently a bunch of 30-minute ones I
think his isn't January that's that's a
good that's a good calling card man I
guess they found out most people don't
go past 30 minutes today that it's a
something like the 22 minute mark so
they say put your best material up front
yeah and it's just a lot of people save
for the end and like heavy load the
ending so if you want to walk away get
feeling but they're looking at
statistics now Dechaine in the beginning
if you don't catch on the first 15
minutes they're out so don't save your
best stuff at the end yeah an hour
you're used to you know and how stuff
but tell me it's a minute
five for your best [ __ ] the last 15
that's stuff yeah oh how about of course
I mean delay are talking about kicks
I'll tell about shopping in New York
because they have this place called
stadium kids there who gives terrible
prices I took a picture of these shoes
that I bought these crushed velvet Air
Force Ones and Chris goes those are sick
great shop in New York
oh yeah the best he goes dude go broke
like do you give horrible advice they
know to spend all your money out there
it's great I love all of them what uh
what do you would you do this weekend
cat still working non-stop
yeah basically same old same old
work work work mm-hmm I didn't get to
see the fight although I'm not mad at
your Yeezys today mmm I'll tell you what
that's one thing about my crowds they
dress up very nice and they have really
good shoes yeah I don't know I don't
know said oh my god
yeah it's like yeah yeah very good shoes
a lot of cauliflower on my craft oh yeah
I caught fire ears a lot of dime pieces
would there man and everyone's pretty
dressed for me it's all couples you've
never liked you know I'm not the guy who
brings the girls mmm it's not crystal
yeah yeah daddy's getting older dude
that he's getting older so it's dude and
their girls Co he talks about you a lot
but I don't listen to you it's that kind
of stuff so there it is I'm psyched to
get back on the road we start into this
month I start New Year's at Irvine
improv and then and then I got some
dates January February March you missing
it yet I the love-hate relationship but
I'm also nervous I got to start writing
Indian new I've been writing guy talk
about career suicide is if you go back
the same location that you were in last
year with the same material people do it
all the time I don't know
out of all rehash my old [ __ ] if I have
to I mean I'm not doing that I can't go
you need new [ __ ] you don't want to
rehash your old [ __ ] oh that gets out
your fun you got to come up with new
tricks part of the game in there buddy
yep it never ends either that response
nobody never goes away that'll always be
the nagging sort of like thing over you
for me it is I get a weird thing when I
want to have to write and I'm not you
know what I do do not
do it but then when you started doing it
I don't know that's I do it but what
happens yeah but but if I'm not doing it
I get this weird twitch in my shoulder I
started doing this a lot it's so [ __ ]
weird
price sense of anxiety - I think so why
don't I have a tic
yeah I have a you're not writing tick
yep what time do you guys write is there
dude
is there a time that you guys know - no
I try to set my I do this weird trick
because I heard I read this is somebody
on my podcast long time ago who studied
attention spans and I think 20 to 23
minutes is a good thing you'd do 23
minutes at a time with no phone no
nothing and you can get a lot of work
done and so I'll set a timer for 23
minutes I'm not allowed to look at my
phone or anything just sit I like flush
now do you like I went I met up with
Bert the other D'Oench woman my hour I
did in front of Bert good in front of
Burton just helps a man do you ever
think about doing this or what you met
and some of it connects and some of it
not at all but yeah it's hard I mean
it's dinner day it's such a personal
thing to tell you it's your expression
go with God but sometimes if it's your
material you I need outside eyes on it
do i dude you this is way too long well
I put this here this here so I've been
doing that for so long it you need out I
guess it gets like in your brain it's
hard to change yeah like everything else
you know there's some convention we got
a speaking of an itch I you take a piss
okay go for it you got an itch in your
dick then you should go get that checked
out Oh a little something your voice hey
what do we got guys guy goes first okay
so a woman was arrested because she
tried to stab a man after he got into a
dispute with her because she farted out
loud in a dollar store farting in a
dollar store well so the dude farted he
farted wait that's a woman all right she
farted while she was in line to pay at a
dollar store the man right next to her
said something they got in an argument
she pulled out a knife from her purse
and made a motion where it seemed like
she was gonna try to stab him and she
said
I'm going to gut you but she ended up
walking away and leaving police officers
found her Li gonna have that you also
can't trust a person is just gonna rip
an open fart at the dollar store in line
you know rude that is yeah but also
maybe it's somebody does fart I'm gonna
go but I'm not gonna call you out on it
oh I will if it's loud and like and cuz
I'm the big guy so everyone thinks the
big guy fart I'll be like damn come on
I'll go come on man you don't be like
damn lady you just fart in front of me
but I'm like Jesus at least make sure
everyone knows it's not me
I go Jesus Christ it smells like [ __ ] up
in here like I want everyone to know the
big guy didn't do it if she ripped one
right in front of you while you're in
Lund
like in your like I would laugh like um
were you born in a [ __ ] Zoo the with
the dollar store sorry bad enough man
yeah it's every night I went to the
dollar store everybody my bad mood did
yeah my mom's shop still gets the
[ __ ] really a lot of people it's
actually a good place to go if you want
to get cheap [ __ ] yeah for a dollar
yeah but also it's about enough you're
there we hit this lady in line ripping
farts near bill I'm playing when someone
keeps Florida yeah it drives me crazy if
you don't save sat next to you you don't
say anything I say something I took my
around go come on man I just want anyone
to know that I [ __ ] all it's right I
put my AC all the way on if this guy
next to me are gonna friend me I'll go
come on man so they're like whoa i sat
next to a [ __ ] the guy who fell
asleep and started farting and he was so
[ __ ] heavy and just he had eaten
something and he's wet I was like this
[ __ ] guy Dan ah goddamnit
I didn't hear it but I smelled it uh I
got so mad I was like this is the worst
and then I wake and he puts his goddamn
earphones on he's watching some terrible
sitcoms going ha ha ha
look this is the worst you're the worst
sir oh you're the worst I'll wake him up
I'll act like I hit him on acting like
oh I'm sorry I just gotta you gotta get
a keep him check me I couldn't breathe
you gonna die right in front row the
time Jay ripped I'll fart in the green
room and I was
well we simply can't have that because
there's waiters coming in and out and
now they said I gotta get ready for a
show it smells like a [ __ ] my buddy
can't climb up in here I go please don't
do that he's no prompt doesn't get on it
I gotta be honest get out yeah I had to
kick Jacob out of the green room we're
at the earth the linen library I'm in
high school there's a girl I loved loved
I say a lot I didn't like her a lot I
school original high school love Rachel
ups 1917 and we're in the library and my
buddy was the kind of guy who would fart
and loved it and didn't care if I go hey
he just goes to dot that dot I go do it
and it's stunk and so Rachel's there and
I go oh my god and he goes Rachel come
here
oh no I don't know don't come here you
know if the others don't
it's great so come over here she's like
what you guys just come on what are you
gonna do wait and they like that she
goes why I go no Rachel don't come here
don't Rachel no come here
and she gets into the cloud she goes I
swear to god it wasn't me yes it was so
funny everything so [ __ ] up yes so
funny was so [ __ ] up man what does he
get so a 9 year old girl wrote a letter
to Stefan curry that her dad posted up
on Twitter asking why there weren't girl
sizes of his shoes and he found it
responded and gave an explanation that
kid sizes are universal but they put it
under boys specifically so they didn't
have a girl version he ended up sending
her the shoes told her that he would
give her the first pair of his next
shoes that will be released on
International Women's Day and he plans
on bringing her out to Oakland for after
a letter like that I know just just so
the women know that we also we believe
in gender parity yes we just believe in
gender equality get on Steph Curry man
but to hold on is doing a basketball
shows you how good Steph Curry is he's
about your most important person on any
team because the
Golden State words have been in shambles
since he's been injured even though they
have Kevin Durant and everyone else and
klay Thompson without Steph Curry
leading the way they are [ __ ] really no
they wouldn't win without him damn what
else yet she's the best 3-point shooter
like ever I heard this was some say yeah
so Southwest Airlines issued in an
apology great how about this guy huh the
Greyhound of the staff Greyhound of the
sky yes they are actually they issued an
apology because one of their workers
made fun of a little girl's name and her
name is spelled ABCDE do you guys know
how to pronounce that name ABCDE
I don't want to show you guys a birdie
well sir first of all this woman's all
right these outpatient make fun of my
girl yeah it's a mom basically angry
about the Zetas mama yes what's the
kid's name now AB City absolutely oh
yeah that's how you pronounce yeah but
you know but but hon how hardcore did
these grown-ups make fun of her they
really didn't it seemed like they just
chuckled
diabla see and she was offended and she
I don't it's free tickets AB City lab
school name but she wants free tickets
so tell her shadow it's just the mom
complain here mm-hmm
let me see let's see how offended she a
gate agent started mocking my child's
name laughing pointing at me and my
daughter and talking to other employees
so I turned around and just said like
hey I can hear you so if I can hear you
my daughter can - like I'd appreciate it
you just stop okay and so what do you
want to happen lady you want south let's
give you free free tickets for life your
kid's name is very unique ABCD gun
pointing like ha like that's not how
holy this stupid girl no they're
probably but but it is weird if I got
wrong like no I'm telling literally his
name yeah you mom cuz it's because you
just revolta that's it yes she gave a
kid of names that she has to litter this
Veronica miracle who's the mom she's a
reporter
she's a NBC ABC reporter I think yeah
that's a reporter alright but it's like
all right dude the problem is that you
give somebody a kid's name like that the
rest their life they have to explain it
for sure
my name is ABCD no it's not a mistake
it's absentee uh it's a cool name though
I have to say what I think it's awful
it sounds like a mad like a little
sorceress named absolute obsidian a b c
d e oh yeah there's other ways to spell
ab city this is what says right here
though AB like city like a SAP city oh
my god mom mom mom's kind of she did
that for herself yeah that's just the
alright what else we got yeah so 50 cent
made headlines cuz he commented on his
first son's Instagram photo and said
that he wouldn't be mad if him and his
friend both died why or will not guide
but got hit by you trying to be funny
you know no yeah he has a very long and
tumultuous relationship with his son he
put if both of these little [ __ ] got
hit by a bus I wouldn't have a bad date
Wow
way to go dad I have zero ill war
ill-will towards anyone living on this
earth the people SH annex son looks up
to an associate through his reflection
of the negative energy embraced towards
me I paid his mother 1.3 million dollars
port to afford him opportunities I never
had aa man there's a young kid he
probably hates his dad his dad try never
around so [ __ ] enough for descent
hates him out know the whole story
rocky relationship with his son for
quite some time due to Bart nasty split
from his mother the power producer and
top Tompkins date for several years in
the 90s during the Bowser upper-mid that
having limited contact with ego who was
11 at time Wow
my leadership with my son is changing
because damn his mom came because he and
his mom aren't friends anymore there's
different channels I have to go through
his lawyers point him through the court
stuff to talk to his Laura to get things
he's great for me Wow well he can
understand why the kids upset with him
yeah also don't say that yeah did you
say that Thompkins filed a suit against
$0.50 earlier in the year legend that he
promised her the house value at 2.4
million more than a decade before
50 cent sue Thompson alright blah blah
blah she get a [ __ ] job he wrote
fantastic but but also let me just stop
everybody for a sec also what you don't
don't write that you feel my calves on
that grab my calf and I talking about
oh my my hands burning yeah don't don't
don't write that no don't write about
your sons that Halle Berry he's own ass
no no vivica [ __ ] yeah she's a diamond
diamond of all time yes she's wish what
I said no not anymore they broke up a
family him anymore um he seemed to have
a long what I was gonna see both at have
like falling outs with him am I wrong no
you're right yeah his crew his own crew
g-unit they like had beef mayweather
like he's that problem with everyone you
see I have Scott Coker watch her back
but also but also like you said that
about your own son
I'm sure you have your reasons you're
angry you did that publicly and
deliberately it's not venomous did you
ever see this one's funny though did you
ever see Deion Sanders when his son
who's up he's a freshman or like
sophomore in college
put doing it back in the day ghetto
style like he was cooking something and
Deion Sanders got on his Twitter it's
Deion Sanders the greatest quality of
all time went what the [ __ ] do you know
about growing up ghetto you grew up with
a silver spoon in your mouth you're the
son of Dion's
like just roasted them was like you
don't know [ __ ] about growing up get
alike I did the kid was all but bring it
up Deion put Deion Sanders troll son or
fiancee and her son social media yeah
don't [ __ ] you say you know [ __ ]
about throwing rock you're Deion Sanders
[ __ ] kid yep Deion Sanders shame son
on Twitter there you go
cuz he kept saying I like it growing up
in the hood the hood stuff then he's
like excuse me sir
do you not see his thoughts Deion
Sanders jr. and he put gotta get the
hood donuts almost every morning if my
donuts don't come in plain white box I
don't want them and Deion Stan split
you're a Huxtable with a million dollar
trust fund stop the hood stuff yeah I'll
tell you that hood doughnut I'm almost
every morning I forget whose son plays
for Deion was on first take though he's
a well known him a little bit he's a
great [ __ ] guy such a stunning guy I
don't play baseball and football on a
high level hmm yeah well he does now
he's out yeah we're doing well you know
Deion Sanders from the best genetics of
all time like none of the kids turn out
to be monsters huh SMU Mustangs
yeah Southern Methodist University in
Texas
sighs d1 yeah boy Jeff Anders son you
went to Florida State ran the past 40 of
all time yeah that's him to go and I
always thought Deion Sanders was so
small and I looked at him and I go we
shot something together we spent a week
with him I know how much do you I was
looking at his body and I was a guy how
much do you weight he goes to 12 I go
you've seen his rap video well you've
seen as revenue no oh God he has him for
a treat today a monster though yeah yeah
best of all time then he and Michael
Irvin I spend time best of all time he's
to shut an entire quarter of the field
down where they just wouldn't just act
it wouldn't even throw over this that
don't have anyone looking fast now it's
game over it's super old I must be the
money god I want that Falcons Jersey
this is the heyday - now this is that
the heyday Deion by the way yeah this is
like Steph Curry making a music video
now
now do you think he [ __ ] all those
girls in the video such a nice guy look
at that outfit terrible rap song but boy
so gives you an idea that you got it
easily right it's just no musical he
doesn't have an it can't hear the music
apparently can't hear his agent tell not
to do this yeah he's like now I gotta do
everything because everything came easy
like you can't matter you're a great
great football player great baseball
player but that's it's very few please I
can rap as well you're not a singer you
know the best rapper and then I felt
probably white guy a receiver for the
Dallas Cowboys really yeah
type and [ __ ] I forget his name I'll
figure wha
rapping white receiver except for the
Cowboys yep who we think I we have in
the podcast a long time ago that kid
that white kid like stud yeah he's
passing Jelena he is I'm gonna use his
music for my special really yeah he just
came out another album and he's engaged
that's him Cole Beasley Cole busy
rapping educate yourselves now um he
just released a new CD and I think he's
engaged to Jose Canseco's uh daughter
real he was in the Victoria's Secret
Fashion Show last night have you seen
her
I know but he's a stud he's good-looking
yeah he's super there you go he's the
best rapper in the game right now in the
NFL wipe boys [ __ ]
[Music]
oh it's pure cold it's cold back on the
mic what was like the life inside of a
beat like a slight bow thought I was
going but I'm never leaving I'm coming
rip it not surprising this ear good he's
really good and I don't know rap but you
can tell he's good the kids on street
who say he has bar flappers he wrote
this this is really some trouble but
[Music]
he's a little slot receiver with the
Cowboys brawler - men Cowboys aren't
Arora now first place a real athlete yes
real athlete yep Dallas Cowboy anything
rap I don't give the whole career in it
but we don't know who says a sidekick
though [ __ ] someone say football is a
full-time job
no you're for sure but what's your day
like when you're that guy in season
right now so play on Sunday Monday rehab
Monday off Tuesday game plan walk
through Wednesday like this where'd you
get the watch tape the tape and the the
team would give you the handouts for
like that week's team ok break down the
team then Wednesday walk through
Thursday or Wednesday like practice
Thursday walk through you know so so
when you're when you're in seasons not
bad I'm not getting beat up in the games
not during the so when when you are
watching tape you're watching the
defensive backfield if you're a receiver
if you're him you're watching defense
you're gonna be up against and what
their yeah their schemes everything like
that and they give you a whole scouting
report and what you should look for and
then they have the offensive game plan
that you got to go over goddamn it so
strategic damn run your routes dude run
your route I think ease might be hurt
them you know what I do I go where the
ball is gonna be it's gonna be I don't
wait for it to go that make sense dude
you know I'm saying I run my route and
I'll be where the ball throw the ball
I'll be there I say this to the code
I'll be there I'm not trying to be a
dick I go throw the ball bro well what
are you gonna throw the ball
I never yeah I'm gonna coming back
though he's probably in the lab coming
up with some dope rhymes while he's
injured okay hopefully keep their house
would tell season been good he's a
[ __ ] studies
teams terrible no offense line or
quarterback it's a big problem I wish
they would trade them with us yet
let's see miles here be the man yeah
speaking of football cream hunt from the
Kansas City Chiefs a video came out of
him do you see this I didn't see the
video who cream hun is I do he's a
running back I believe for the Kansas
City Chiefs some would say the best yeah
one of the best yeah as far as fantasy
he's the best
so he's like that T this isn't like some
just like now he's dreaming wrong Ray
Rice was good but cream hunt is a
[ __ ] monster rare just getting going
super in town yeah and I out of a job
down well I was let me see this can I
want to give you my do watch it I didn't
I didn't okay you watch it I'm liking
the same thing you watch it and tell me
what you think
chin have you seen it I saw it cat have
you seen it tell me you guys weigh in
and I'm gonna win there's no audio but
you can see what's going on audio so
he's he's talking to a girl girls
walking up to him then he pushes her
pushes his friend and pushes her again
she slaps him even this like right now
everyone's trying to hold him back this
whole happen with Tosh
she'd this her excuse the rumor is she
don't sleep with his friend yes then he
was like get out char call him the
n-word this is where that's the big
spill right there so he he goes back
behind the wall yeah comes out pushes
his buddy and his buddy ends up pushing
her against look even that's not the bad
part that part is when she falls yeah I
think he pushes his friend which runs
into her that's okay that's okay pushing
this friend yeah me too I'm like right
this isn't too bad
I'm fine with this so far because this
is he look pushes her chief the friend
pushes her no proceed even this I'm like
right boy what the [ __ ] she hit her head
yep but here's the problem this is where
he really look so you see he's in black
there watch he kicks the girl that's
where he's [ __ ] now not hard but he
kicks her riding on the booty we're
right here see how she's there
alright kick so that's what [ __ ] them
when he kicked her in the booty like
that now he didn't [ __ ] Spartan
kicker but he kicked around them that
looked like a very light like kind of a
touch so but here's the thing
he kitchen really should never be
allowed in him before he way on this
yeah should that man never be allowed to
play professional football game and not
do his job so I don't believe that
that's a so so so what I saw was him in
and before you go and before this
remember she called him the N word yeah
multiple times okay so here's how I feel
first of all he gave her a little shove
because she was in his she's for coming
at him so he gave her a shove he pushed
his buddy and then as he was leaving it
looked like he didn't I I don't consider
that a kick I consider that I like he
went like this
he gave her a nudge with his finger I
was like yeah yeah if that's what it was
get the [ __ ] out of here now
she called me n-word now in my opinion a
young man who's heeded I thought he had
actually really kicked her very very
different okay really she called him
this this word should he lose his job
forever absolutely not so no I thought
no I thought I thought I kicked her
investigators have had this video for a
long time again guess what the
prosecutors did nothing said said that's
be hard to press charges for this yeah
so then this video gets out yeah and the
public you got him fired yeah that's
right they got him fired now does the
NFL goes uh because the unfolding come
after again coming back at yes yeah so
she's coming back at him she was fine
she just hit her head now here because
he pushed these guys trying to hold him
back he's what do you probably he's
probably very strong she's coming she's
coming and I want to say this as well
she doesn't look very intimidated she's
not sober either yeah she's an aggressor
I just got aggressor look she's the
she's the aggressor trans push that guy
she just pushed that guy now she hit on
our dream hunt didn't push her no he hit
his friend yeah so that so that's so I'm
not advocating you know what you're
saying what you're saying is that he
should be banned for life for doing this
to it to something just push her in the
beginning though hold on you want
attacking she's attacking him watch
watch this watch this
she just called me my she's not really
attacking but she's getting a face face
y'all saying n-word so but my thing is
though she can go back and wear
right does she lose her job no now what
what what kind of responsibility does
she take in the threaten she's just
right she's a girl man you can't touch a
girl that's tough to touch a girl but
when you call it because feminists would
be like wait a minute
cuz we have to put everybody on the same
okay well if you want to be treated like
a man we can do that actually got WAY
worse just you understand understand I
know you're saying because because now
now there's a real double standard
because women are because if this is a
dude yeah if you want to do it the same
you call in the n-word visit wolf this
is a dude you're getting punched in the
face but even let's say change
everything change her out for amazed
fine here's this the cream hunts crying
tomorrow you 100%
so my problem with this is a it's not
bad he be he should have done it he
should have been suspended for this do
let's get crazy suspended four games out
paid that's hundreds of thousands of
dollars for him never to work it yeah
we're saying yeah no teams gonna touch
him he's been Ray Rice yeah I think
that's now comparing him to Ray Ray Rice
knocked his fiancee out drugged her out
of the elevator
that guy he's a dude this was softness
yeah this guy what would what what a
young man like this should do is get the
[ __ ] away but she did call me if she
called me in where is that true his
buddies validation hold on she came in
there cuz she's all I want to sleep with
a friend and so II was like I well then
get the [ __ ] out it's 2:00 in the
morning what do you think we're doing
here trying get a dick sucked yeah she's
like not on my watch he's like cool get
the [ __ ] out she's so she's an [ __ ]
yes she sucks but what repercussion says
she suffered she goes back to where
she's working right now yeah
is that fair it's not it's not it's not
fair and we live in an environment where
it's a very strange thing because it's a
it's a very it's this whole thing on
gender parity and we have to have like
women have to have equal everything
that's fine problem is there's a huge
double standard the minute a man touches
does does that he takes all the blame
she takes none of it he loses his entire
livelihood but I thought we were all
equal what's up I thought we were all
equal it's such a if he had beat her up
if he had done the Ray Rice ball so I
ready to watch it yeah way ma'am oh when
I see that [ __ ] like that other baseball
player who hit that pisses me I was like
that guy's should be in jail forgetting
losing your job go to jail okay
is this where he wear what he did was he
nudge her and he has to get out of here
[ __ ]
correct and he any pushed her when she
was coming at him I saw ever coming at
him I don't know what she was saying
there well it's just like remember the
Oklahoma kid for his name Peter she's
starting running back for Cincinnati
Bengals now that I go they shouldn't
draft them because he not he'd knocked
out that year oh yeah now that that's
super intense but then what's the
backstory there she has to take some
[ __ ] hold on causing the n-word he
goes get away from me she follows him
into the restaurant yeah bothers him
there harasses him there calls him the
n-word gets in his face pushes him he
responds right Sox are in the face
breaks her jaw right
that's indefinitely not the thing to do
not touch him but but but at some point
you're saying to take and you're also
saying the punishment shouldn't be what
you're talking about is a form of death
well you do Kareem Han has one option
that's play football okay what you're
talking about is let's finish him for
life you're talking about total
destruction and don't say it's anything
else but he's bagging groceries if he's
not but it's not like he got fired from
Starbucks and Starbucks and [ __ ] go work
some no no no no you were banned from
dad lately and look at her pushing she
just pushed him back guy too so she's an
aggressor as well what's a bummer but
we're both aggressors but you guys are
doing this I'm not doing this right when
he's a young man oh I know what else you
know when I was young I didn't do but
I'm not saying he shouldn't be
disciplined what I'm saying is he
shouldn't lose his entire livelihood off
of this cuz even the cops who showed up
when there's not much minute there's not
much a lack of judgment I guess what
he's a young man in the morning in Vegas
lacks of judgment slips and judgment
doesn't make him a bad guy doesn't mean
he has to lose his entire [ __ ] life
the woman does shouldn't get a free ride
here neither
no no what else you got that's a bummer
Wow
is there a chance is there any is there
any room for a reassessment well the NFL
in your opinion he's so good I would
imagine he gets picked up next year
what's this dies down because again if
you're just a human being you're looking
at this come on I'll tell you what you
know what you know what
the real promise these [ __ ] and a
fellow nurse you go oh man we're gonna
stay away from that if you were a
[ __ ] real man if you're one of these
owners you have billions of dollars you
go hold on I know the current culture
everyone's ass me to movement he messed
up but we believe he's not a bad guy
we're give him a second chance
if I'm the Dallas Cowboys I'm the fight
whoever the Giants I'm signing that kid
tomorrow promise corporate it's not
going ends to these extremists well no
because you know why they don't do it
because I'm Pepsi coke [ __ ] papaya
chief Lagos we're out cuz your [ __ ] I
grave all of them a bunch of [ __ ] agree
dude and the more we got you know what
drives me nuts and Michael reports
guilty of this I'll tell this to his
face
you know drives me nuts with like Neil
Tyson with a hunter grass dies not Neil
deGrasse Tyson
I'm sure 20 of current events so there's
been some sexual assault claims against
him we don't have any facts we do not
know what we can't do as man is go [ __ ]
this dude I can't believe he did this
don't don't be a ho this is for you
rapport and I'll take to rapport this
but we need to blast out this right and
goes the guy's always been creepy I
believe it's like dude I said yeah
that's it come on are you doing here
your your your destruction and the mob
mentality yeah that we don't know I
don't know anything about the guy I know
I know anytime I've heard any action
with me baby I know listen to him I know
he's an amazing person
now do I know he's innocent I don't but
one until I get all my [ __ ] together
until he is convicted in the court of
law
I'm not gonna cosign this like a dick
Ryan but also being shamed like former
assistant Ashley Watson has claimed that
de Grasse tried to convince her to have
sex and made unwelcome remarks she said
she'll quit the job due to the overtures
now he's making a pass is making a pass
and and misjudging again and making even
like just trying to get laid because
that is the law is that against the law
and also should you lose should you be
publicly humiliated publicly embarrassed
your Netflix lose that nothing let's be
a National Geographic lose everything
and she's a publicly embarrassed I I
don't think so I think this is taking
putting women making women victims who
can't defend but also so Tyson tried to
convince her to have whatever job
so-and-so
she quit in China who know it's the
accusers degress types of drugging and
raping her there's no guarantee that the
allegations lead to any action against
Tyson if investigators claim have it
merit again again can I ask you a
question be like if that happened that's
a that's a rape allegation was it
brought to the police then was it but
what happens in this situation here's my
thing let's say in some weird world now
that Tyson super famous right yeah the
most famous physic Astrid whatever the
astrophysicists on of all time
especially the current culture yeah it
was would they come out and try and ruin
his name if he wasn't he was just a
regular tenure professor would they do
this here's the other thing if that grew
says she raped him let's say in this
weird world she's making that up what
happens to her nothing she goes to work
tomorrow yeah nothing and he loses hey I
think we're in a time when a lot of
women are angry and rightfully so if you
look at the history of this because they
never had any recourse you're always
gonna have the pendulum has swung all
the way over to this side it's gonna be
a matter of time before it comes back
maybe we're we have some but cat you're
a woman give us your take be honest and
don't worry about on which I'll let us
weigh this what do you think of this
what do you think of a guy that would
give me the Eifel to give me the
football one first you saw the video
that's your first time seeing it yeah I
think it's a shame that he got banned
because where I grew up there were quite
a few girls who would act the same way
who think like oh they're not gonna lay
a hand on me because I'm a girl and I
can get away with this and people have
allowed them to get away with this type
of behavior whereas when somebody
finally says no stop like this isn't
okay suddenly the guy's an [ __ ] the
guy's the one who's like oh he hits
women or he does this he does that and
I've also had several friends who've had
really bad relationships end and girls
come out saying if you leave me I will
tell them that you hit me had it done
had it done so I think it's unfortunate
but I've also seen the other side where
they're actually kidding yeah where
they're at where people have actually
been domestically abusing I feel let's
assume your boyfriend yes
Zozi stays in line by the way okay break
clap bring up my girl at the time
yelling out the window stop hitting me
stop hitting me opening the window go
and stop hitting me I went to my
neighbor's I go just so you know they go
we know you didn't hit her we know we
know her we didn't like her I was like
yeah but by the way have have had that
happen to me so scary
well it's just it's it's what we're what
it is she's not a bad person she wasn't
a bad person she was just really mad at
me and she knows that a word we're both
fighting and she knows it we're trying
to get back at me in that moment and it
was it was what it was now no nothing
happened but in today's we're all here
how to do try and hit you can't really
cared like I've had dated two women that
wailed would get drunk and go crazy beat
you up try to try to and by the way
here's the other thing and I have my
dear friend my friend Todd Todd saw this
and you'll meet him one day he'll tell
his story my friend Todd saw my
girlfriend at the time she thought I was
looking at a girl I had a party at my
house party going on she got drunk and
decided I was looking at a girl who I
wasn't looking at and she just came at
me and and hit me in the head she
usually hit me in the face he then
attacked me and watch what I did was I
went I can't have this in front of my
guests so I opened in a violent nope I
picked her up around the waist and
carried around like a stack of books and
I and I and I kicked this sort of the -
I have those you know those oars yeah I
kicked those open and brought her into
the garage
Jinja and then she started fighting me
and trying to grab me and bite me and I
held her down does she realize and yep I
held her down I got on top of her it
held her arms down as she was screaming
and my buddy Todd goes just so you know
I have a witness I saw everything
I saw it all I go dude that's what I
live with so we've all been through
missiny was she she was of Latin descent
that's all i'ma say by the way drugs and
loved her loved her no no drugs justjust
just a crazy [ __ ] bottom line is what
I'm saying is this we've all been
through relationships where the men and
the women behave in less than
appropriate ways and if you've ever been
in those situations men it's just
and women hit men sometimes - oh yeah
yes and men and women both make up [ __ ]
about each other
yeah here the moment right I just don't
until we find out exactly what happened
to Tyson fellas let's not jump on that
team listen no girls night damn you see
what he tweet I'm gonna suck his dick
don't be that guy don't be a ho
don't be a male ho well it's tough when
you're an athlete they're always I think
they're usually warned nowadays it's
like hey dude
there's a no following college in
college and then Phil there's you have
meetings you have meaning yes yeah cuz
you you'll see you're reading you have
meetings yes because there are the
summit there for a reason yeah yeah
because there are people who there are
some desperate people out there and some
angry people and unstable people and
they're very hot so when they're in high
heels and a lot of makeup it can get
very half figured out yeah you're like
you know what else we got well just real
quick that girl that accused him of rape
drugging and raping they ended up they
weren't dating before they dated in the
past for a little while and he said just
let the investigation do the you know do
its work and then believe whatever their
investigation says don't believe me
they'll believe them yeah Tyson goes I
encourage a full investor I say I would
say by the way that this will go through
an investigation and I think the grass
Tyson will be fine yeah for sure
now it's also this is also very lose any
jobs I don't think I think what's gonna
happen is gonna be put on hold I think
the investigation is gonna come through
and I think he'll be back now but but
but let me tell you this is very very
embarrassing and there's a lot of my 30
years as he yeah yeah there's a lot of
damaging now that he must he did that
girl this you know this a longest time
the OL deGrasse Tyson is a guy who does
a lot of good and if he made a cool he
made it cool maybe cool it's a baby and
I was like after his book I bought his
book made it cool man we need publicans
like no let's but let's bury that he's
also a black man sorry he's a black man
who sets an example for people of color
and young men of color and all that [ __ ]
to be all politically correct
come on man he just came out with this I
mean I'm I'm the accused so why believe
anything I say and it's super long so we
won't have time for [ __ ] let the
investigation go down yeah that says
basically yeah he was I welcome any
about anyone's to look into it interview
those people do that and get back to me
that's the way to deal with what you
don't do is go silent what else again
there's a quick one on Tyson Fury a lot
of people were making memes about the
way he just sprung up see the one I
posted no can you see the boss logic
undertaken while oh yeah it's that one I
just thought it was incredible here's
just a couple real quick they did you
undertake one with the music on these
two wait is it this one here well this
is the one I think these here it is it
is
[Music]
well sure there's some better ones out
there you go to my other that's the
that's the boss logic did it by front
it's literally him the Undertaker cast
that's such a great picture it's
ridiculous
that's such is it that's [ __ ] I would
love that as a print in my house but
it's so sick yeah all right what else we
got this radio station in Cleveland is
not gonna play baby it's cold outside
anymore because of the me to movement
however I feel sick it wasn't the radio
stations decision on their own
they did a poll it's a great song okay
you can't say baby anymore no no not
that no there's a line in the song where
the woman says what's in this drink
if you baby it's cold outside well in
other words alcohol so I'm trying to
loosen you up that's what's in the drink
try and get my dick that's whiskey I
love cold day you're great it's the
great Ray Charles like rendition with
what's-her-name well let's just write up
this Brian okay I really can't stay baby
it's cold outside I really can't stay
baby it's cold outside to go way and
hoping that you drop in this evening
spin oh it's so very nice hold your hand
there just like ice my mother will start
to worry beautiful watch your hurry
my father will pace the flow listen to
the fireplace roar really I better
scurry beautiful please don't hurry
maybe just half a drink mo put some
records on while I pour neighbors might
think baby it's bad out there
hey what's in this string no cabs we had
out there
I knew how yours are like starlight hi
guys that's it huh that's Lisa what's in
this drink so you think it's good it's
cuz it's a it's a it's a drug you [ __ ]
again yeah this is one of the neighbors
my classic songs you [ __ ] you I have
no respect for you
get it together are we this [ __ ]
sensitive baby what's in this can I tell
you something when people are this
sensitive about a movement or they're
this sensitive about [ __ ] I feel like
they don't actually they don't believe
that it's strong enough to withhold the
test of time no losers come up with
these complaints right no one come on no
one doing anything successful anything
worth your time is protesting baby it's
cold it's unbelievable no one that's
ever done these how it's worse to owl
has ever protested but this is shilling
with this is the [ __ ] we're dealing with
I think one of the great songs
what what's in this dream I thought that
now if it was like what's in Australia
maybe it's roofies in there more cancer
cancer what about that maybe just a
cigarette more no set no songs about
cigarettes either what the [ __ ] are we
talking about it's a romantic song
working on it you really been grand it's
wait till you touch my hand I mean come
come on man he's in love I really can't
stay more [ __ ] you [ __ ] losers I can't
even have a drink with a nice young lady
unbelievable so it was the fans they did
a poll with the fans that listen to the
station and the fans are the ones that
didn't want to hear it so that's kind of
why he justified its you guys are
[ __ ] yes they're just so ridiculous I
don't have friends who would do this I
don't have to vote on this I do not
conversate with people who'd vote what
is this are they worried a rape song is
that what we're talking about they think
it's sort of sounds like date rape oh oh
yeah that's why they wrote it you
[ __ ] yeah he's I mean this is on
believe he had date rape in his mind you
this is the kind of insanity we're doing
like something like do we need a Grinch
girl wise to why Santa Claus a male we
need mrs. Claus yeah I know
you [ __ ] hoes you [ __ ] hos frost
you the snowman's a mad man we need miss
frosty tell you what on this podcast
we're never gonna stop
the way we feel I will [ __ ] your snowman
what dude I'm so sorry oh wait I thought
we were going you know I can't first of
all I have no idea where that came from
I call the fireman is know we were fired
up but a snowman's cold I know I don't
know what do you know that I I know
there is his Navy SEAL who told now I
heard this I think I heard from a Navy
SEAL I heard from my friend who's
friends a Navy SEAL so let's stare what
noise death they were all freezing
they're all freezing and they were in
the water and they were on the beach or
they run out like a rock and the waves
are hitting them and the guy goes the
first guy the frettin they're all he was
the first guy can get a hard-on we're
out of here you're out we're out of here
oh [ __ ] so something that everybody's
trying to get a hard-on as user jacket
on yeah just to get your to see if you
have a strong mind
that's a [ __ ] better line [ __ ] that
is my get to the warmth figure it out
yeah damn I don't know man that's hard
approach put your mouth on it let's we
gotta get out of here what your mouth oh
so warm god it's good the [ __ ] sea
spray is really good is that your dick
I'm gonna do it now but man whatever you
have to do to get inside bro I guess so
what else we got
we got this oh wait wait what that's no
no no oh no guys how it's terrible let
me see the Brett Martin Brett Favre and
I guess a few other celebrities were
duped into saying anti-semitic stuff on
this thing called cameo have you heard
of this app called cameo oh my god yes
right I thought it was like the weirdest
thing ever but then I started seeing a
bunch of actual celebrities on it so
it's an app that any random fan could
ask there you know where whatever
celebrity they like to send a message to
them a personalized message and then you
get a payment please pick up whatever 20
bucks and go Brevard what was your
favorite game and he's like well my
favorite well they just have stuff
written that you just read it for your
celebrity it's like cool you like I'll
pay a thousand bucks and you'll read
whatever I want you I would say no don't
do it but I mean because you're if
you're going through a bunch of them
every now and then you're not gonna know
everything right so what happened so he
said I'll play this message first this
is actual message
shout-out to the handsome truth and the
gdl boys
you guys are patriots in my eyes so keep
waking them up and don't let the small
get you down keep fighting to and don't
ever forget the USS Liberty and the men
and women who died on that day god bless
and take care what a jaw he's got now
that's probably something about I hate
the Jews here is that what the code
words were all the stuff that he said
Judea on the hands of truth are the
white supremacists that paid for video
he said shout out to them okay waking
them up means recruiting for the alright
the smaller first to yarmulkes well he
that he just got yeah I just read the
message us as liberties the u.s. vessel
fired upon by Israeli forces during the
six-day war killing 34 huh yeah him and
I think soldier boy was also they got
soldier boy to do it so they paid a $500
in he does that I don't know how much
they paid I think for a fee of $500 ok
bunch of dudes they're soldiers you know
you just say you bet you listen this is
the way it works I'm actually in a the
way you work you so I'm going to so you
do that and then it just says like at
soldier boy underscore 777 this and then
the what your shoutout do you guys know
about Fiverr it's a similar platform to
this except for it doesn't have
celebrities it's a bunch of normal
people who will get paid to say things
by whoever pays there was a youtuber
named PewDiePie who did that to see if
they would absolutely say anything as a
test and he paid somebody uh it was to
Indian dudes from India to say death to
all Jews just to see if he would say if
they would say it and I'm getting they
don't know the English language they
didn't know what they were saying they
made a video saying that and then people
got mad and called PewDiePie a racist
for doing it Jesus is out there
[Music]
this is just a super random one so this
photographer was arrested at a wedding
she was a wedding photographer but she
had sex was one of the guests and then
peed on a tree outside of she why would
you arrest like a good save in her body
what 26 year old and here's no there's
no problem here's her she's a bikini
model - yes why did they arrest her
she's because she does she peed on the
tree yeah Jesus
well she's outstanding and I love that
sex outside I can't tell where that is
they'll take Malibu dude hos love Malibu
well I mean first of all good on you I
have nothing but good things to say and
I gotta rest yeah I can't be sure yet
arrest not fair she could use a full
rack of ribs but whatever I'm very happy
with the whole situation I appreciate
her talent as a fan I know I appreciate
her giving back that's what I appreciate
and you know and she so she peed on a
tree lucky tree dude you lost weight
tree I'm so glad you brought this up Jim
you know it's weird
we need new pictures from find the kid
oh thank you you know what we really
know we our Christmas card I would love
to get out there and to eat and have her
shoot yeah we do the beach but whenever
going takes place in studio in studio
and on Saturday night yeah nice - I mean
your place Christmas yeah yeah love
drinks yeah that's TV it's cold outside
baby it's cold outside
yeah anyway well this is also what she
said y'all's family will be dead by
Christmas y'all's daughters are dead she
told the cops
so she was super drunk [ __ ] my dad is
gonna find out about this y'all are
[ __ ] dead
d e a D daddy
she was daddy dead she was drunk and you
know but why do you say my dear who's
her dad I don't know let's find her
daddy I feel bad for her she also mixed
alcohol with medication this is
embarrassing
like this is embarrassing to a human
being like she had we've all been there
I've never done in one way or another
I'm saying we've all been done
embarrassing things like [ __ ] and peed
on a tree what are we talking about
I [ __ ] outside and peed on trees yeah
I have and that's what I've never been
like y'all are dead well maybe daddy's
gonna
all you maybe she was drunk as [ __ ]
mistaken even drunk I've never said what
looks like anti-anxiety medication
this is [ __ ] terrible to say what her
dad's nose does leave her alone just do
that I mean go back up please I want you
know what you know what you know what
she needs she needs you to laugh can you
tell me laughs Brian and Brent that's
what I'm seeing some relax and I guys go
for massages right come to us and I'd
like to be I'd like to welcome her back
with with the open are we'd like to pay
for your wine is you pick the hotel
ography you pick the hotel nice photo
shoot some pictures will be taken on my
phone I'm a fan some on yours fan all
the way around full supporter you can
bring your daddy bring your dad bring
your daddy you know you have two daddies
waits outside uh-uh
wait you don't to bring a daddy because
daddies are waiting waiting waiting
she's a she I'm a huge fan yeah she's
right yes sir hopefully she pictures
these nuts in her mouth Wow what else we
have to the last one I have is this
everyone's been hitting us up about this
so we had to show it the big Nick big
neck hey man I stumble on words
big neck guy guy good well that's the
end of our podcast I stumbled my work
it's that big neck and long neck big
door jingles Phil mouths I said big neck
yeah you wanna be's let me see the video
of the meeting both offs the abnormal
he's smaller than I thought to the big
neck guy that's what makes it look more
ridiculous
all necks matter these boys got nothing
to do huh
well he's a celeb now for what for
whatever 15 minutes
this guy that do the Sun this weird [ __ ]
why next panic the long neck guy what
about him he has like a million
something followers on Twitter at the
Instagram woman I just checked Instagram
it's amazing well I don't know why they
write that stuff I don't know who owns
this account good for them maybe it's a
apparently the Wynette guys trying to
take a fight too right yeah MMA fight
and may or boxing the CEO of that
organization is allowing him to fly
bears think it's hilarious yeah that was
that's pretty much it that's hilarious
well it's a few things Chin's racist of
course and and we are no degrasse tyson
is not the predator you wanted to be
correct and you're not gonna stand for
it now we're not understand I'm not
photographer who's looking for daddies
yeah look no further no further we're
here here you know how to contact this
right I do need new headshot it's gonna
[ __ ] us you're gonna focus you said if
you get rid of babies go outside any
snowman I see from now to Christmas I'm
gonna mouth but okay well it's gonna be
hard to keep stay hard Jesus yeah she's
um I'm a delicious yes I'm a fan she
taxes not met us in dance floor it might
be half Indian
sounds like an Indian Middle East Indian
Amy I met that is usually an Indian
named Catherine Lee met her so I believe
in I'd like to see guys she hooked up
with that I know that the party yes
Steve what we're working with here
anyway either way Bravo on her and no no
no actually did that [ __ ] um anyways yes
show it to her Brian I'm headed to New
Mexico first time Albuquerque dude
sounds an Albuquerque estrella Jackson's
now I'm there slaying in jokes god
dammit
quit bringing up a hot chick shot shot a
TV show in Albuquerque desert we call
that the high desert I'm gonna enjoy
some green chili yeah
I'm enjoy Santa Ana Casino this Friday
and Saturday two shows Friday Joyce a
strong widow satyrs a thing you enjoy
green chili Albuquerque this Friday and
Saturday and then the only other show
this month I'll be at the Comedy Store
here and there but the only time there
in Albuquerque with the Jackson which I
said that dude then the other full
weekend December 28th 29th the Ice House
in Pasadena will be me and some friends
who are much more funnier than I am than
January 10th through the 12th just hit
the streets Edmonton Canada
I'm coming Edmonton and then the big one
January 19th show time when our special
in San Diego California both shows are
almost sold out Spreckels theater tea
fat K back time for tickets also Brian
you know our army green app Kenny Fight
Club T's drop tomorrow
I didn't finally got him I find got him
J shop our Black Friday with the baby I
need two mediums I was sold out I need
two mediums damn it Albuquerque New
Mexico see this Friday and Saturday
tickets Deepak a Tom this is a fired kid
we're out